es ist das größte bisher entdeckte
schwarze loch und es ist das jüngste nur
875 millionen jahre nach dem urknall ist
es entstanden und damit ein rätsel wie
konnte ein so riesiges schwarzes loch
entstehen
es zeigt sich mal wieder dass wir nur
wenig über das weltall wissen wir
bringen jetzt ein wenig licht ins dunkel
im wahrsten sinne des wortes bei klick
zum 26 herzlich willkommen wie entdeckt
man ein schwarzes loch eigentlich sind
wir ja unsichtbar schwarz leben aber wir
haben eine eigenschaft die sie
normalerweise ganz leicht auffindbar
macht die akkretionsscheibe die massen
sie in das schwarze loch gezogen werden
heißen sich dabei immens auf und fangen
an sehr helfe läuft es bietet sich die
sogenannte akkretionsscheibe und genau
so findet man ein schwarzes loch und
jetzt haben die wissenschaftler ein
solches sehr helles leuchtendes objekt
aus der anfangszeit des universums
gefunden
doch es ist wie immer in der forschung
es werden ein paar fragen durch die
entdeckung erklärt und es entstehen aber
zahlreiche neue fragen
hier ist vor allem die wie konnte so
kurz nach dem urknall ein so riesiges
schwarzes loch entsteht galaxien haben
so nimmt es die wissenschaft in flüssen
als gesetz an ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch in ihrer mitte in unserer
galaxie ist es vier bis fünf millionen
sonnenmassen groß ein großes loch
braucht ihr auch eine galaxie um sich um
überhaupt genügend masse in der umgebung
zu haben die es auf die größe eines
supermassereichen schwarzen loches
anwachsen lassen kann die galaxie ist
quasi eine erweiterte akkretionsscheibe
die aber nicht aufgehalten
bei dem neu entdeckten schwarzen loch
würde das aber eine riesige galaxie
bedeuten die sich um das schwarze loch
kopiert der anteil der masse des
schwarzen loches an der masse der
gesamten galaxie ist typischerweise so 0
15 bis 0 5 prozent das neu entdeckte
schwarze loch hat eine grösse und jetzt
achtung von 5 milliarden sondern machen
das heißt dass die galaxie um das
schwarze loch vier bis neun millionen
sonnenmassen haben müsste das ist
wirklich riesig zum vergleich unsere
galaxie hat ein schwarzes loch mit vier
bis fünf millionen sonnenmassen in ihrem
zentrum dieser galaxie wäre rund 200 mal
größer als unsere galaxie war und sie
ist ja nur eine von milliarden anderer
galaxien
das universum ist einfach unfassbar
riesig die forscher sind jetzt so
richtig heiß auf weitere entdeckung da
die aktion scheibe des schwarzen loches
so hell ist können sie jetzt die
metallgehalte dort untersuchen und
erfahren so mehr über die
sternentstehung im frühen universum und
wir suchen jetzt weitere solcher
schwarzen riesen im frühen universum
ich bin extrem gespannt vielleicht gibt
es ja auch aus dieser frühen epoche des
universums weitere hinweise auf mein
lieblingsthema die dunkle materie ich
bin gespannt
hier geht es übrigens zu einem sehr
spannenden gedankenexperiment für denken
dunkle materie die könnten nämlich aus
schwarzen löchern bestehen ja und wenn
es euch interessiert er unbedingt eben
da drauf klicken und den helfer packen
wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst mir auf keinen fall im
anschluss einen auf die glocke zu geben
ihr wisst schon ansonsten bitte bleib
dran